wir sind einfach lama wir sind viel
langsamer als als andere auf der welt
also entschuldigung das ist doch jetzt
wirklich schön wenn ich da jetzt
wirklich sehr direkt werde wirklich sagt
du bist zeugin schauen sie wahl in
großbritannien haben die jetzt über
81.000 tote tier aber das ist doch
nichts daran dass sie schnell einen
impfstoff die politik nein sie können
nicht ernsthaft erzählen dass die korona
politik der britischen regierung um
einen deut besser wäre es habe das ja
auch gar nicht gesagt ja ich habe mir
nur gesagt dass großbritannien schneller
impfen ist und das können sie in jeder
statistik nachlesen ja und jetzt schauen
sie sich mal an wie es im moment in den
britischen krankenhaus das ist ja nicht
meine frage jetzt kommen sie schon zum
fünften andere krankenhäuser nicht so
einen unsinn als er kann unsere
großbritannien in irgendeiner weise wäre
als bei uns tue ich nicht hermann
konsequent weiter gekämpft wir wir
werden konsequent versuchen so schnell
wie möglich jeden impfstoff den wir
kriegen können entsprechend einzusetzen
dann kommt jetzt dann auch der von der
firma moderner auf dem markt und wir
wären mit dem impfen konsequent
vorangeht